il faut se souvenir que l'italie est un
pays très neuf est un pays où l'état
n'existe pas ou est très très peu
existants l'unité il ya deux unités de
base en italie il ya l'unité sociale qui
est le village qui est la famille pardon
et l'unité territoriale qui est le
village et c'est comme ça que dans les
très grandes difficultés économiques ou
ce débat ce pays aujourd'hui c'est comme
ça que la population survit et donc la
dérive de ceux de ce système clanique
familiale et villageois et bien sûr le
pousse à son extrême ce système de
solidarité devient la mafia les deux
fait une forme de système mafieux avait
investi une partie du vatican notamment
à travers la banque que à travers la
banque du vatican
vous soulevez un très très bien un
cardinal de curry qui m'avait expliqué
qu'ils n'étaient pas italien et qui
m'arrive qui m'avait expliqué qu'il
était courant de voir des messieurs bien
ni avec plutôt l'apparence d'hommes
d'affaires qui venait voir d'autres
cardinaux de curry et qui leur
expliquait tout le bien qu'il pensait de
l'église des actions de solidarité de
l'église et qui à la fin de l'entretien
transmettait des mallettes pleines de
billets en liquide comme ces courants en
italie en italie on transporte beaucoup
liquide ont pas eu beaucoup en liquide
et très souvent la machine de la carte
bleue est en panne et donc à ce moment
là l'argent pouvait ainsi rentrer dans
la banque du vatican et la banque du
vatican à l'insu de son plein gré de son
plein gré
servette organismes de blanchiment et
donc tout ça tout le monde le savait
tout le monde le savait et les cardinaux
du monde entier souhaité remédier à cet
aspect un peu noir de la gestion de
l'organe central de l'église de la curie
et du vatican
et donc c'est en partie pour cette
raison là que le pape a été élu
[Musique]